today in the night Kiev in Kiev
would have been hit by a combination of
chemical
missiles hyper sonic missiles
dagger we know immediately in the Solomko
area de Bachimo the Great crater is
literally
10 meters to the side and there were a large
number of victims in one
second one woman on the
road to Shvidal Shvidko
died in
our country  [ __ ]
30 people at a time there are carved
injuries in the spiers of the
hospital
there are people at a time nadaetsya additional
help is important bsh x
missiles Bula beaten by mi bachimo tse ulamki I do
for our armored forces against the back of the
defense Ale Tim not mensh ulam inflicted on the
great Skoda is in trouble and the
energy supply system is
also tied to them at the same time  by the end of the day raona
un
roku znovu blow russian nonhumans mayzhe
100 rocket tives schonaymenshe 70 missiles
zbi them mayzhe 60 in the Kiev area zhorki
hit the bulls and in Kharkov dyakuyu all svit
hto help patriots Iris nams kozhna
taka system vryatuvala even shonaymenshe
hundred alive And for kozhne  the living Roya Vda
Slava was stolen,
but it fell, it hit hard and the
glass of the
apartment window began to fly, oh my God, what a
terrible fear, just think about
that. Here are
the conditions of five mo
in the
territory of ten
pi